[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and broadcaster
Jenny kleeman and the editor of the
Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons but
first let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now a Big Splash in
the mail on Sunday reporting that the
personal mobile phone of former prime
minister Liz trauss was hacked during
last Summer's conservative leadership
campaign by agents believed to be
working for the Kremlin
the star offers a light-hearted take on
the story lettuce Liz hacked by mad Vlad
The Observer understands advisors to
Rishi sulac aren't happy that his
predecessor Boris Johnson plans to go to
the cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt
because Mr sunac doesn't intend to
in the Sunday Times that decision is
criticized by the prime minister's
former cabinet colleague alok Sharma who
chaired last year's conference in
Glasgow
meanwhile in the Sunday Mirror there are
claims the prime minister's leadership
campaign was partially bankrolled by
donors with ties to fossil fuels Sky
News has approached Downing Street for
comment
the telegraph is that Mr sunat wants to
stamp out what the paper calls woke
policing practices
according to the express He has blocked
the idea of a 250 million pound
replacement for the Royal yacht
Britannia put forward by Boris Johnson
and the people pictures Amanda Knox and
Raphael solejito reunited having been
accused of the murder of the British
student Meredith kircher more than a
decade ago
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Jenny cleeman and Jake Wallace Simons
welcome to you both let's start with the
mail
headline there Kremlin hacked trusses
mobile and off the back of this labor
calling for an investigation take us
into this story Jenny
uh well it has emerged that Liz chos's
personal mobile was hacked by the
Kremlin by suspected Kremlin agents this
summer when she was a foreign secretary
during that first Tory leadership
contest uh and there were exchanges with
International allies that may have been
overheard and with Liz trust Liz truss's
biggest domestic as Ally quasi quaten
there are fears that um
she may have said some embarrassing
things that may have been picked up by
the Kremlin and this was discovered then
Boris Johnson knew about it the cabinet
secretary Simon Simon case knew about it
uh the decision was made not to make
this public at the time just imagine
what it was would be like to be a spy or
an agent working for MI6 and knowing
that the foreign secretary's telephone
could be hacked wouldn't you be fearing
for your safety I mean we have also a a
home secretary that leaks things uh so
you would be worried if you were in any
branch of the intelligence Services I
think uh reading all of this it has to
be the case that that this sort of thing
can't happen apparently this phone is so
compromised it's being held in a secure
government location locked away
somewhere at the moment because it's
such an incredibly leaky phone maybe it
needs to go to the bottom of the North
Sea like Rebecca vardy's agent's phone
because uh because it's such a a
dangerous thing for our enemies to have
access to yes it's been locked in a
safer at the moment but it's understood
that messages which could have fallen
into the hands of foreign agents
including criticisms that mistrust and
her future Chancellor Mr cuarteng made
over Mr Johnson Jake
that's right there is serious National
Security concerns coming from this as
you've said there are some criticisms
apparently of Boris Johnson being shared
by Liz truss and quasi-quartang which uh
you know obviously raised his fears that
she could be open to blackmail could
have been open to Blackmail at the time
there are also conversations with her
International allies including we think
um about arrangements for armed
shipments to Ukraine so it's in quite
seriously sensitive top secret
information here that seems to have been
achieved
um obtained by the Russians via hacking
um the mobile phone which is you know
the soft underbelly of society everybody
has everything everything you know in
their life on the phone
um and with the minister it's very
dangerous indeed so I think the real
question here is um why it was leaked
now
um you know there have been some people
raising questions as to why we weren't
told about it at the time
um but certainly in my opinion these
sorts of things really should be kept
top secret while the internship services
do their job uh and don't advertise to
the fact that the enemy has has achieved
these sorts of approaches of National
Security it's also the story covered by
the the star but in quite a different
way shall we say Jenny they're
continuing this lettuce theme aren't
they
well you know when you've got a winning
formula Why Stop people have been very
excited to see what's on the front of
the star ever since it's hit on it so
it's lettuce Motif which of course is
originally came from The Economist that
a lettuce was living longer surviving
longer than Liz truss but then the star
really took it on board and now they've
managed to combine it with another of
their favorite tropes uh mad Vlad there
you have it uh you know it they make
they make a joke out of it but Jake is
bright I mean there are first of all
it's very serious that this can happen
at all and you have there has to be a
really serious inquiry into how this
could happen uh did she click on
something was something put onto her
phone this should not be able to happen
but also the idea that uh she could have
been blackmailed she was the Prime
Minister of this country did they have
compromising material that would put her
in a a difficult position you know we
cannot allow this to happen and whilst
the front of the stars is funny this is
really no laughing matter yes sir and
they they are
injecting a bit of human but even they
are suggesting that it is quite serious
trust us it's beyond belief Jake
yes it is yeah no pun intended is beyond
belief
um but yeah I mean as Jenny says it's
very very serious indeed
um I mean she isn't she's by far the
first politician to have been hacked in
this way uh internationally I know in
various cases where this has happened
often with very very high ranking
politicians uh using a variety of
techniques often uh aggressive software
that's able to access the phone from
afar
um and you know in this day and age you
know our security services do need to be
across this stuff and it's you know it's
all very well supporting Ukraine with
you know all the amazing uh Firepower
and resources and expertise that we are
but if we undermine our own position by
allowing our mobile phones of our
politicians to be hacked by the Russians
it rather goes against what we're trying
to achieve
to the times Jenny and this story about
uh cop 27 it seems that it's not uh
leaving a bushy sunaka alone after he's
made his decision not to go
um alak Sharma previous president
um well the president until a couple of
weeks time of uh cop 26. he's actually
come out against Rishi sunak and his
decision not to attend
yes well Alex Sharma lost his cabinet
position in the recent uh reshuffle so
did the climate Minister Graham Stewart
and you know we have to remember that a
year ago at cop 26 Alex Sharma was
crying at the end of it from the stress
and the strain of trying to get an
agreement through this is clearly
something he cares about very much and
we have a prime minister who has said
that he's not going he has more pressing
matters at home I remember a year ago
where there was much consternation in
this country where we were still very
much in the midst of a of a pandemic
there was consternation that Xi Jinping
the Chinese president wasn't going to be
appearing we expected that and now a
year on from us hosting cop 26 in
Glasgow our prime minister says he's too
busy uh with with things at home and and
what Alex Shan is saying which is very
interesting is he's making comparisons
with what happened in Australia and the
Victory of Albanese in Australia and
saying that voters are going to uh I'm
not going to forgive the government if
they show that they are not interested
in climate climate issues
um so these are strong words from alak
Sharma he's clearly aggrieved uh but
perhaps justifiably so this is somebody
who clearly puts his heart and soul into
cop26 last year now no longer in the
cabinet uh with a prime minister who who
doesn't think it's worth this time to go
to cop27. yes Jake and uh his quotes
here I'm pretty disappointed that the
prime minister is not going I understand
that he's got a huge intro of domestic
issues that he has to deal with but I
would say that going to cop27 would
allow for engagement with other world
leaders and I think it does send a
signal if the Prime Minister wants was
to go about our renewed commitment on
the issue
um do you agree with that that it it
signals to others that it's not top
priority for the the UK
well I think the first the first thing
to note is that this is a quite a heavy
criticism from alak Sharma of course
he's he's no longer a minister so he's
not bound by Collective responsibility
but nonetheless the whole point of the
Tory party at the moment or the main
thing they're trying to drive towards is
unity and this is this is the really the
first uh sort of major departure from
that note of unity that Richard like is
so desperately trying to achieve but
aside from that I think that Alex Sharma
does have a point it does seem very
strange for Richard not to be turning up
to cop 27 particularly as Jenny said
given the high profile nature of the
event last year in Britain
um but the strangest thing of all really
is it doesn't seem to be part of a
joined up strategy on the behalf of
Richard sunec on the one hand he's not
going to cop27 on the other hand he's
reversed uh Liz truss's full steam ahead
with fracking he's brought the band back
in so it doesn't seem to be a coherent
strategy is he against Green policies is
he for green policies what's his
position we seem to be getting mixed
messages here meanwhile we read in the
Observer Jenny that the as well prime
minister Boris Johnson won but
um before is on his way to cop27 he is
going to be attending cop 27 according
to sources that the Observer have um
spoken to
yeah this is going to be very annoying
for Rishi sunak because it's making him
look bad
um here is something that Rishi sunak
says he doesn't have the time for he's
being accused of being myopic and Boris
dungeon is just not going away his
ambition is as big as ever he wants to
maintain his high profile his global
global profile and we know that King
Charles is not going to be going even
though he wanted to go so this will be
the most high profile British person
walking around in charmel Sheikh he will
get all of the attention and we know
that Boris Johnson wants to run for
conservative leader again so maybe this
is a sign of things to come Jake is this
just provocative of Boris Johnson
I've got to say I mean despite the story
on the front page of the Observer I
would be very very surprised if this
actually did take place it would be such
a divisive and disruptive move from from
Boris Johnson
um and I think that the the results of
it would be very unpredictable he
wouldn't necessarily uh achieve the
popularity that he obviously needs if
he's going to ever have a chance of
being prime minister again and his
friends have been saying to journalists
recently that he's biding his time so if
the you know the ball comes out the back
of the scrum again he might be there
ready to take advantage of it so um I
would be surprised it is actually does
happen
um and don't forget King Charles
although he's not attending himself he
has announced that he's hosting a
reception at Buckingham Palace to world
leaders prior to cop27 so he's making um
you know he's making a gesture and quite
a serious one uh those worldings are
going to come to to Britain to uh to
meet British officials every student
will be there as well but yes for Boris
to go to to to Egypt I think would be
divisive I would be surprised if it
actually does take place the paper tells
us several sources close to Johnson did
not deny that he was set to go and asked
whether Johnson was attending cop 27 the
cabinet office which was in charge of
cop planning and preparation said it
could not answer directly so watch this
space we shall see whether he attends or
not Jenny and Jake for the moment thank
you we are going to take a break coming
up is British policing too politically
correct the new prime minister
apparently thinks so we'll discuss that
next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Jenny cleeman and
Jake Wallace Simon there you are I
thought you deserted me for a second
right we're gonna have a look at the
Sunday Telegraph
and um this article is telling us that
uh Rishi sonak is going to concentrate
on Law and Order on um crime I'm not
going to use the word that's used in the
headline because I'm Banning it so
you're not allowed to use it either
go Jenny oh dear that's a challenge yeah
it's a really annoying word officers are
criticized for apparently sending police
to police social media users or uh to
take the knee and apparently that's
getting everyone up in arms and that's
what's wrong with the police force not
the fact that the police force has
various police forces have massive
problems with uh misogyny with
homophobic banter with the murder of
Sarah everard uh Bieber Henry Nicole
smallman all of the rest of it but
apparently this example set by greater
Manchester police are putting more uh
Bobbies on the beat and and
investigating every crime is going to
make everything better and that's what
Rishi sunak wants to do because of the W
word that's um
I mean I would say
I don't think most people think the
problem is uh the police being too right
on I think uh the problems there are
many many problems uh the new crime
figures that came out this week shows
how low the charge rate is and then the
number of cases closed because the
victim doesn't want to pursue it anymore
has risen by 25 that would suggest there
is something about the way the police
are doing investigations that is
alienating the public not the fact that
they're too busy policing people for
tweets and it's newspapers like this
that get very head up about woke
policing I don't think many people
really feel that that's why they're not
safe because the police are too busy
taking the knee the suggestion is that
police officers need to get back to
basics and following on from this
um
police chief in Greater Manchester who's
taking a sort of a hard line approach
um which Rishi sunaka has been much in
Praise of and that's the suggestion that
it needs to get back to old-fashioned
policing Bobby's on the beat and
concentrating on cracking crime Jake
yes which is zumac is seeking to emulate
the example of Stephen Watson the chief
Constable of Greater Manchester police
who's able to turn around the force in
about 18 months from one that was in
special measures to one that was
achieving a good standard of policing
and he did that by focusing minds of
officers on going out on the beat and
persistently pursuing leads of every
single crime until they solved them you
know it sounds pretty obvious you can
call it old-fashioned policing but I
think most people would think of it as
simply policing
um and I think that Rishi is right to
try to divert the attention of police
forces away from that sort of virtue
signaling self-branding I suppose of
wearing rainbow colors and dancing the
margarenner and uh in the most Sinister
manifestation of it policing people's
tweets and uh and so-called hate speech
or non-crime hate speech or whatever
it's called
um of course Jenny's right that the the
problems facing are police forces are
far greater simply than being a bit woke
there are very many deep problems in the
police force including employing
officers who themselves have criminal
records yes who've engaged in some
professional behavior and bullying and
so forth so it won't solve it
but it will help
just time to talk about uh Liz truss in
the Sunday Times and um her List of
Demands when when traveling Jenny
oh I feel a bit sorry for Liz trust now
uh Harry Cole and Jace Hill have written
a book out of the blue this biography of
Liz trust that had to be hastily
Rewritten because she's no longer the
Prime Minister after 44 days in office
and they say they reveal her Riders
whenever she went anywhere she wanted
double espressos always locally produced
always served uh in a flat white sized
takeaway cup you had to take an espresso
machine with her wherever you went if
you were working with her you had to
have chilled white wine in a fridge
waiting for her no pre-made sandwiches I
read this and I think yes
it's not that bad it's not like she was
asking someone to take all the all the
brown M M's out of her packets of M M's
and I just I feel sorry for her and I
also feel very sorry for Harry Cole and
James heal who have written this this
biography of our least successful and
shortest uh prime minister in the
history of this country indeed Jake one
sentence from you
yeah I think that that book really
should be called back into the blues
shouldn't it